my name is ed barrett
and uh
welcome to the corbett uh poetry series
at mit
sponsored by comparative media studies
and writing uh program at mit
uh tonight i have the pleasure
and it is a pleasure
to welcome david thorburn
reading from his recently published
first book of poetry titled knotts
david is a distinguished professor of
literature and media at mit
and a beloved and award-winning teacher
to generations of mit students who have
taken his popular film class film and
literature
as i mentioned
david will be reading from knotts his
first book of poetry
with the title like knots you might
expect poems that are written in you
know
a naughty difficult to untangle style
but the poems at least in my reading of
the book in this book
are written with an open direct style
embracing
family marriage
sex
sports
history
and now and then a greek god or the 50s
tv character ralph cramton
it's a subtle quick paced book
just like life
after his reading david will be happy to
answer
questions
uh comments you're writing in the chat
um
[Music]
thingamajig
uh and he will respond to uh to those
questions
so please welcome
our new poet
david thorburn
thank you ed
uh i'm very grateful that was a very
generous introduction and thank you
everyone who's here colleagues former
students
family
thank you all
dressed for the day
dressed for the day at 93
in flannel shirt and khakis
he warned me to keep the coffee hot
and was a corpse
three minutes later
i touched his arm
raised and dropped it
i touched his forehead
he seemed asleep
but cold
he knew
nuts and rigging
varieties of the hammer
marlin spikes
masonry
copper
that's the first poem in my book
the
book was
although i've been writing poems on and
off all my life
uh uh jiggering with them and playing
with them
uh i i'd never thought
seriously about publishing more than an
occasional poem i never thought of
myself as writing a book of poems
but a spurt of
grief and creativity combined
caused me to begin to write much more
seriously when my father died
and that poem was the first poem i wrote
although the original version of it was
three times longer than the poem than
the poem i read to you and what emerged
was a book uh in which the through line
uh
was the story of my relation to my
father and as you can see it opens with
his death so there's no no mystery about
that and and it isn't actually a
biography of my father or myself but it
may be a kind of biography of the of my
ambivalence toward this extraordinary
man at this extraordinary and in many
ways dane difficult man
uh so there's a through line in the book
in which every few every four or five
poems there's another short poem about
my father all together mounting i hope
amounting to a kind of interesting
portrait and then interspersed with that
are other poems drawn from family life
ed gave a very generous description of
the range of the book and i fear it was
more generous than i deserve because
when i look back at the book i myself
was shocked by how bloody literary it is
and uh even some of the poems are forms
of literary criticism not really
surprising i suppose given who i am
but but uh uh i think actually some of
the most interesting poems in my book
are a kind of literary criticism not
really so surprising when you think that
poetry itself is often that
a form of interpretation of a reading of
the world a reading of objects and many
poems or readings of texts as is this
one
hat-trick
in the adventures of the blue carbuncle
holmes deduces an intelligent
once respectable
tradesman
in degraded lodgings
whose wife no longer loves him
all this from a tattered bowler
whose size means brain power
whose broken chin band proves foresight
corrupted
whose yellowing stains disclose a
stumbling candle holder a stumbling
candle holder sneaking late to bed
in a flat not lit by by gas
unloved by one so careless of this grimy
unbrushed felt
this grimy unbrushed felt
amazing dr watson
not to mention us
inside their
parallel universe
where crime and married life
parse
like this sentence
well one of the things that
um
uh
bore in on me uh after i that that i
sort of discovered with with an
embarrassed shot because i should have
realized this uh
uh when i was asked to do an occasional
reading and i haven't read very often
this is only the third or fourth time
i've read and i'm
very grateful for the opportunity um
but i became very conscious of the
difference between poems that you speak
to an audience even a virtual audience
and poems that you write that are that
you imagine are read in the privacy of
her own space by a reader who has the
book in front of her and and uh it's a
different relationship in a certain way
and uh
there are complications about it that
are that are worth thinking about in any
case here's a poem in which it seems to
me the spacing of the the arrangement of
the poem on the page is part of its
meaning
and i like the poem so much i think it's
a a valuable poem i want to read it
anyway even though i think it needs to
be on the page uh but i i will try to
compensate for that by describing its
format
the poem belongs to the category to the
old famous category of poetry called ek
francis which is
derived from the greek and it means it's
a description it means a description of
any artwork a description of a painting
especially and there is a great
tradition of poetry about this as many
of you must realize uh and this in a way
is my contribution to that
conversation um
but the
uh conversation is complicated by the
fact that the full effect of the poem of
my poem depends on the ending where
after the poem is over there is in
italics right justified a replication of
the legend that's posted about the
painting which i'm describing in the
poem uh in uh at the bottom of the frame
and the
poem in a way depends on what happens
when the reader gets there so i i
thought of reading this first but that
would spoil the experience of the poem i
just guess it means you should listen
extra
extra carefully
because i think i intend i suppose that
the reader be driven back to re-read
the poem is titled leaves
leaves
in the leopold museum in vienna way up
floors above the sullen sheilas
their grimacing gaudy [ __ ] and faces
and jansen's yelling pencils of himself
bug eyes
bloating cheeks
hair and the top of his head dissolving
irradiating out and away like nebulae
after all these paintings a winter
pastoral so modest you almost pass it by
hundreds of withered leaves
floating in windless air
bring dull color to a regiment of
slender trees
stalks of white bark
branches
the children
two of them
in winter wrappings small against the
trees
and empty sky
foraging for beech nuts
in the snow
theodore von hormann 1840
1895.
1892. peasant children in wintry beach
forest
oil on canvas
painted in dachau
bavaria
morning watch
tiger loose on deck
first mate thorburn tackles his captain
to stop him firing the handgun
rips free of his shirt to wave it like a
flare
or so he'll tell it years on to his son
as the creature coils in the early glare
and starts her death by water
in the fiery air
i remember when i first wrote this poem
i got a kind of thrill
an impulse that maybe you're really a
poet when i had the triple rhyme of
flare glare air
not so surprising but for a first time
poet a very very exciting a very
exciting discovery
excuse me about that
well one one of the things one of the
things i i
uh like to do
um is is um i'm looking for page numbers
here right pardon me uh
one of the things i like to do sometimes
is play is play with titles uh use
titles that that aren't that don't
exactly mislead but that have a kind of
ambiguity in them and maybe mislead
slightly in one in and i i i i i hope i
have time to read two examples of that
uh stratagem uh um in in in in a second
so the first of these uh poems is called
quibble
quibble
i see them quibbling over our stuff
loving as they are at heart
who gets the kitchen burra
vampirey woman chomping lunch
who'll want the brass lincoln bookends
abe's poor abe's right arms
casualties of our march to boston
which of them will have the message of
the mediterranean bedroom
hardly scuffed dear
after 45 years
your library of architecture
our dictionaries
i fear dispersal
and dismemberment
well here's another of those
kind of poems poems with tr with what i
guess modestly tricky titles
i'm sorry about the page turning it's
bad
for me not to my book my bookmarks fell
apart a bit
this pain this this poem is called
bridling
breidling
at the insinuation he's [ __ ] to his
master
the bridler toys with revenge
maybe bridling my lord's big chestnut
with a virgin bit
she'll spit in rage in half a mile
and rub his [ __ ] hours our soul
off her back against the willow branches
in the swamp along the river
how many boys and men
in saddlery
and harness making then
then
he's not primitive
technology deprived
but literate
generous
adept among his world's deep systems of
transport
caste and commerce
he won't bloody the grand creature's
tender mouth
lucky for puck's nose
and selects a gentler harness
hating how she lifts her quivering lips
to take the iron in
here's a poem
here's a poem for my basketball buddies
running the break
not rushing is the secret under control
never full out but in a range of speeds
keep the ball to the top of the key or
else the foul line
ready to pop from 18 or bounce pass left
or right
or take it down the lane and dish
or kiss it off the glass yourself
or take it to the rim
or kick it to the shooter in the corner
well i mentioned uh
uh a moment ago
that that uh
i was struck when i began to think about
the oral presentation of poetry
about how much more vulnerable and
intimate you become when you have a real
audience and when you're speaking
and there are poems in my book that make
me very uncomfortable to do that uh with
uh and uh
but i thought if i mentioned this at all
i had to give you an example so this is
one of the poems that that uh
and i think i think it it demonstrates
why uh if you think about it as an as a
message that i might send to someone
sitting reading in her room why that
would be an easier message an easier
confession about my family's stories to
make
not to mention more scandalous kinds of
confessions that are typical of
confessional poetry
it's a very rich interesting topic
great oral presentations may not be the
best kinds of written poems
anyway here's a poem
cremains
when she came out to you it's no excuse
that you were 90
and claire no longer there to steer you
from your brutal deeps
weeping she hears you say you cannot
love her anymore
and then
that sailor's tale of murdering queers
at night
this isn't the worst that can be told of
you either
i wish it could pour out of me
your stories of square heads calacts
messino's
the saddle cinch used more than once on
me and andy
but then you're teaching me hand tools
digging
the constellations
the slingshot you carved
mythic gift to your david
perfect organic why of oak
the sling a rigger's gift
a sculpted tool for killing rabbits
and small birds
at times i want to spit in your ashes
still in their blue canister
cremains of frank thorburn
shelved in a back closet
where no one goes
sometimes
one of the things i discovered as i was
began to write really seriously was how
much poets need need encouragement and
how tender they are when they're given
criticism even when they claim they want
it
um and uh
i showed some i showed the poem i'm
about to read to a number of friends
including a couple of poet friends
and they were
quite negative about her and i was very
down in the dumps even though i liked
the poem
and then i showed it to another poet
friend his name was joel agee thank you
joel and joel got it joel loved the poem
joel understood what i was saying and i
resolved that i had res uh a new rule
maybe call it the four burn agey rule if
one person really likes your poem
publish it
here it is
palest fires may still sear
we know of course that for the jews of
europe
the messiah did not come
says mr spock on npr
in his earthly guise as the actor nimoy
introducing lauren bacall to read
bernard gurney's english version
of isaiah spiegel's yiddish story
of the dog
nikki
a dog story
bereaved by hitler of his master
jacob simon tempkin fur dealer
and later exterminated by machine gun
with his mistress the widow anna
nicolaevna
in the loads ghetto
husbandry
in the stench and the black of the
animal hold
on the adam mckenzie out of liverpool
you speak softly to the arabian
calming her with danny deaver
and
invictus knowing from your parents farm
that horses need human voices
fear confinement
come to harm like children
you will feed her carrots
sugar cubes tennyson
every day of the voyage
then supervise her hoisting in rope
harness you designed and rigged to the
pier in brooklyn in brooklyn
she'll be bulky entering the van
and you will until you gentle her
and receive your tip of fifty dollars
from the owner
two more to go people
two more poems
this poem is my uh entry in the
conversation that poets like to have
about their own funeral arrangements
and some of you will
discover
uh
will hear
some uh
cut homages to to my better to my
bettors to some great poets who have
written poems of this sort in nepal
at davey's earn
at davey's earn let no one wear a tie
let all smoke dope whose mortgages are
paid or children gone from home
or mates content
no prayers or seminars allowed
no art displayed
let's start in twilight on my backyard
deck
and eat and drink enough
to keep our talk alive at least through
three or four a.m
when some may go but most of you stay on
for songs
poached eggs and vivid argument
to keep my drowsy empress awake
and save the earth from ill
and fix the sky
oh
wait till dawn before you say goodbye
last poll
dream work
car repair was not in his repertoire but
here he is
working a ratchet wrench under the hood
of my blue station wagon
the 68 ford with a hot spot in the cargo
area where the kids would dry their
bathing suits after the beach
he turns from the work now
hobbling strangely
my shoes he says where are my shoes
the kids are grown
and far away
the shoes are ten years gone to goodwill
with his decent shirts
and the wool and long johns he wore at
sea
before he came ashore
to make me
thank you very much
thank you david
can you hear me yes
thank you very very much songs and
poached eggs on your backyard porch i
think we don't like to be there
this me too
um
there will be some questions and
comments perhaps and and andrew will uh
moderate them so that i don't press the
wrong button and suddenly uh
turn on the air conditioning um
um
i have one quick question for you and
it's very open-ended
uh you've had a distinguished career as
a scholar
you
have your first book of poetry published
how does that feel
what's your process for writing a poem
my process is writing 80 years i was
waiting 80 years for the for the courage
the truth is i uh to tell you honestly i
i i actually think
now that i reflect on my barked career
in some ways i've had a wonderful career
and i don't mean to denigrate it in that
way but i've written much less than i
intended and i've struggled with my
writing much more than i have wanted to
in my life i'm proud of what i've
written and i think i've written
important work but i've written much
less than i expected to be able to and
it's been a real burden to me i think
that one reason was
that i had a kind of poet's tendency in
me from the beginning but couldn't let
myself acknowledge it or see it
and there are a couple of reasons for
this one is my temperament i mean i'm a
fuss
it's i think part of what makes me a
very good writing teacher because i
can't bear to let it even mistakes go by
so i fill my
my students comments with my students
papers with ridiculous
grammatical complaints you know uh so
there's a kind of uh fus budget side to
me almost an obsessive side to me about
trying to get things exactly right which
which poetry can allow because you can
work on single lines for so long right i
would often do this in my essays and and
it would take a long time and then i
would get into horrible arguments with
editors especially when i began to write
popular culture as essays about
television and forms of popular culture
because the editors i was reading were
how to put this gently
uh
less well-read than i would like
so i would i would put in illusions
really famous lines shakespearean lines
that everyone knows and they would they
would edit them and fix the grammar and
things like i would get in these
ridiculous i re and i a lot of my career
was spent in time defending my pros
against editors i thought were
often were much younger than i and much
stupider than i and i realized that that
so so in any case what i liked was to
work on sentences
and and parent and and i think it also
had to do with the attention span right
but i could but but the other thing the
confession i'm making is this
i went to graduate school
i was surrounded by great poets
people who be i mean
friend dear friends of mine but people i
admired and that i shared seminar rooms
with two of them became poet laureates a
third i think is a poet at least as good
as those two
uh
it was an environment of such remarkable
poetic intensity that i was i was a kind
of fringe member of it uh and i was
friends with those people but i think i
was i think they intimidated me without
my acknowledging it to myself
i can't be sure that that was true but i
to be honest that's what i think it was
and i also think to be really honest i
was able to unlock my ability to write
poetry when it was too old to matter
when the competition was over it didn't
matter i'm still very grateful that i
was able to write these and i do regret
that i didn't uh take it more take this
quality in me more seriously i have been
writing poems all my life and some of
the poems in here i started many years
ago but most of them are an old man's
poems because i became a better writer
as i got older and the final point is of
course i don't really think in the end
that there's such a big difference
between my best paragraphs and my best
poems i think i wrote really good prose
and i think the
the attention i gave to my pros was
unusual i don't think it never happens i
think there are many very great prose
writers that i admire tremendously um
i can
i'll name two that will offend people
they're both
political conservatives or thought to be
political conservatives even though
they're not one is simon shama the
historian
i think he's one of the greatest prose
writers of english who ever lived
another prose writer i tremendously
admire is stephen pinker
now they're not poets and they don't
write with a poet's compression but i
admire them very much so i don't
those are some of the reasons but it but
it is also true that reading my poems
to audiences even the few times i've
done it this event tonight was so much
more
valuable moving rewarding
pleasurable to me than any lecture i
ever gave and i've given hundreds of
lectures some of them really good to big
audiences i'm proud of them they were
good work but reading your own poems
boy i wish i'd had this experience
all my life as you have ed
but that's enough that's enough of this
i'm very i'm grateful for the chance to
have done it and i believe i believe in
these poems i
i believe that these are good poems i'm
i'm i'm grateful to have had the
opportunity to have lived long enough to
have written them
thank you david i'm going to pass it
over to andrew who has been collecting
uh various
uh
questions coming through in chat
yeah and i'll just disappear andrew is
that the idea
not too fast but yeah yes
thanks
so i thanks for that wonderful generous
introduction that was really wonderful
thank you for a wonderful wonderful
reading david
absolutely wonderful
um i wanted to comment how nice it is
looking at the
attendee list and seeing so many people
with the last name thor boring oh
i think i think that's great are there
so many i didn't know
five or six at least
there are a lot of uh well i have three
boys three children i have two
granddaughters i should have at least
five there my wife hasn't come i guess
i'm gonna be very unhappy
and a number of other familiar names and
one of them uh stephen tapscott um from
from literature has a question
saying i admired and enjoyed these poems
when i read them in the book and so it
was interesting to hear you revising
some of them or critiquing the aesthetic
on the fly as you presented them and
that in turn makes me wonder if you're
rethinking aesthetic positions how or
why
which further makes me wonder if you're
writing new poems and if so what's new
how do they differ from
these passionate quote early poems
what's to look forward to
thank you stephen that's a very generous
question um
i guess i i
i am i am still trying to write although
i'm writing with the same slowness i've
written a few new poems that are i think
are okay but these poems took me like
even after i got serious about 10 years
all of them are much long were much
longer in their original in their
original form
if i have a
style i guess it would be called
minimalist
right i once wrote a poem called uh
a mission statement then i realized it
was so bloated that i titled it nearly
streamlined mission statement and then i
wrote another another poem called
mission statement and essentially the
this was the mission statement
um
don't lie
scour scour each line and the spaces
between them scour each poem scour them
scour each piece of punctuation scour
again
that's my that's that's my that's my so
it takes me a long time but i i have
especially because there's nothing at
stake except my pleasure in the work
um i have gotten tremendous pleasure
from this kind of whittling away at the
poems and making them as short as
possible one thing i've tried to do and
i've succeeded in a few poems that i
think
friends of mine i respect have said
they admire uh are their poems without
any punctuation at all
they go sometimes i'll put a period at
the end
they're poems without punctuation that
are still
they're they're perfectly readable even
though they're quite long i mean in fact
the first poem i read is an example of
that
if there was no punctuation in that poem
and that's i was bragging a little when
i said uh in the last line like this
sentence the original version was like
the sentence like a sentence but then i
got boastful and i said like this
sentence because i was so proud of what
the pullman had managed to do
not a full answer to your question steve
but a partial one so i am still writing
uh i don't know if they're changing that
much but i i did change the poems on the
fly because i became aware of the
difference between hearing a poem and
having it being read to you as against
reading it and i felt that i needed to
give even though i had to violate
some of the lineation
in order to give a kind of emphasis
appropriate to an oral presentation and
if i had thought more about this
question i might have done more of that
i i it is not a question i thought
deeply enough about but it's very
interesting to me
i remember my friend former colleague
and poet barry spax many of you may
remember him he used to teach at mit and
then he went to california where he had
a wonderful career as a poet spax was a
magnificent reader of his own poetry
very dramatic he could put on voices and
so on and i often felt that his poems
were much better listened to two than
read this is a cruel thing to say about
a wonderful man who was kind to me and i
admired but i think it was true he wrote
and he wrote book wonderful books of
poems many books but hearing him read
was a far more memorable experience than
reading his poems by yourself
i guess i hope that's not true of my
poems
i don't know i i hope i read well
i i apologize for searching through my
book that way for the pages i had marked
them more carefully but my page markers
fell out
out of my nervousness before i began
reading
great
um let's keep one thing in our back
pocket here uh stephen oh no sorry uh
richard cross wonders if you might be
able to read knots so if we if we have
time
a kind question should i should i wait
to do it
it's it's the title poem of the of the
book and the longest poem but still none
of my poems are very long as you can
tell this is so maybe
uh right it's too short pages long it's
not a long poem i'd love to read it it's
the it's the title poem by the book and
it does give a a kind of
um
additional uh energy to this to that
spine of stories about my father
all right uh let's take one question
then and then how about you you read
that one nick montfort if i can find my
book yes i can yes okay nick asks uh how
has your experience as a poet publishing
and reading your work changed your
teaching of poetry
frankly nick it's made me want to teach
my own poems
i mean i
mean i mean i i became jealous of the
attention that we're giving
but the truth is it's made me
i i would reverse it the fact is the
fact that i think i was always a very
attentive and engaged and even
passionate close reader of very
uh
demanding modernist poetry helped me a
lot
it gave me standards
you know i mean there were there was a
certain level of crap i could not write
because i had been immersed in great
poets all my life i'd been hearing them
and listening to them not to mention the
great contemporaries like stephen
tapscott
who
asked me a generous question or robert
pinsky or
robert haas two poet laureates or or
james mcmichael
an incredibly great poet roughly roughly
my generation
astonishing rich book i mean i had their
voices in my head all my life
so
they wouldn't let me go too far wrong
even though i didn't have the skill to
reach their levels and the
uh
or the experience i mean you know i
sometimes wonder if i had started at the
beginning maybe i could have
talked to them in a serious way i don't
mean to denigrate my own poems i believe
in them very deeply but i also have a
realistic sense of where they belong
in the in the pantheon of poetry
that's great
um wooden kelly asks david when you
describe your writing i think of your
description of your father
gently horses is there a way in which
shaping a poem is like calming a bulky
animal i guess i'm wondering how much
your father the subject of your poems
might also have provided a model of a
writer
that's a very smart question when i
hadn't thought about it in that way i
mean i've always thought of my father as
a kind of model
uh of a kind although also a negative
model as you can see from the one really
negative poem i wrote about there are
other negative things about them that
emerge in the book it's a
not a not it's about i think it's it's a
very it's ambivalent it's deeply divided
so in wins questions very
very acute um
i thought he was a model he taught me
how to use tools he taught me about
precision
and i i do have one poem uh i realize
now that
that that
that that does explain that uh maybe
maybe really
i'm reaching down here from my book uh
does explain that
really really powerfully uh and maybe
the poem will explain it better than
better than anything if i could find it
quickly
um
i can't find it quickly
um uh so so i so i so i won't i won't
bother uh uh trying to
trying to dis trying to discover it at
so late uh uh when we have so little
time but uh
and if it if i find it uh uh in in
in when i'm reading the other poem and
looking through the book i'll i'll i'll
dig it out again but the basic idea was
he taught me precision he taught me he
taught me respect for
um accuracy um
uh he
uh he he had a he had a mathematical and
an architectural bent in a certain way
he liked he he always wished he had been
an architect i think and and uh and he
knew and he knew an immense amount he
was an incr he had an incredible amount
of practical knowledge
so maybe his attitude toward tools and
toward the uses of tools
affected my attitude toward words and
the uses of words
it certainly affected my desire to clean
them and abrade them and sand them down
right and scour them right i mean a lot
of the metaphors i use for working them
do are are metaphors that come from
tools and tool making
uh so to go back to richard cross's
request would you like to read nuts yes
i'll read nuts 34.
maybe this would maybe we should end on
this note okay i mean everyone's had
enough
and this is a
let me find the poem
sorry people
this is because i'm
nervous
i think after all this time all these
audiences
that's another thing when i read poetry
to audiences i'm nervous and i never was
nervous as a teacher
it's something different it's something
wonderful i'm so happy to it happened to
me in my old age
richard's being very helpful he says
page 34. right thanks
richard i i have it already thanks
richard
very homey
nuts
the bride's necklace titles against
resistance
but never fully closes
named and rigged so
by an unknown
possibly scots or cockney sailor 300
years ago
maybe the matthew walker whose namesake
nuts for sale
as a keepsake
in nautical museums in sydney and
dunedin
among the laps and the aborigines of
borneo
knots or knotted garments are taboo
for pregnant women and their husbands
lest the delivery be restricted
no crossing of legs no locking of house
or cupboard
until the child comes
the hangman's noose with nine turns
is made exactly as the hangman's noose
with seven turns
except for the two extra turns
reserved by long tradition
for white men
the cockled neck
aka
half crown sizing
doubles the strength of the round sizing
by forming the eye at the point where
both ropes cross
this loop knot was invented for the
murderous harpoon murderous harpoons
they called dolphin strikers
aboard the old whalers
the secret of the turkish archers knot
is lost
joining slingshot to bowstring
the knot is illustrated and carefully
described in many documents
but no archer in a thousand years
has achieved the killing range
800 yards
of the ancient bowmen
who made this knot
sacred to allah
the knot in your belly
from bad clams
the one in your chest for angina
the not in my head and heart when i
remember too much
a fellow in his frenzy says the heart is
a cistern
where foul toads not engender
the triple hitch has saved many lives
including said my father once or twice
a drunken dutchman lonely for his wife
who pitched fed headfirst into the
forward cargo hold
and dangled swinging by his hitched
right ankle
laughing and vomiting before they cut
him down
to hose his mess
before the morning watch
on the ss california
new york to san diego
via havana
and the panama canal
the knot of hercules
secures the girdle barring entrance
to vestal virgin's most sacred parts
our oldest
the square knot
sometimes called the reef knot nowadays
so strong and perfect to its uses
its strength increasing
under strain and use
that it was said to be the gods
invention
and was remembered in erotic rites
once widely practiced
on patrician wedding nights
the bridal gown
held barely shut by this god's knot
is gently
is gently
nibbled open
by the groom
thank you david
thank you for your beautiful poems with
us and thank you all for
uh attending
and uh
we're off to spring thanks again david
that was thank you very much for all of
you for coming